hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
[Applause]
july 4th 2022
[Music]
oh you fat fox go out and get your
sunburns and your fire works
hey
oh man i was traveling dude i'm back by
the way oh sorry a little too loud i'm
back everybody uh if you're wondering
where i was maybe you weren't
you know maybe have a life outside my
podcast or maybe that makes me feel
things in a certain way that maybe i
didn't feel like feeling them on such an
early tuesday morning doing a monday
morning podcast
i um
i did a run of dates
y'all i did a run at [ __ ] dates that
took me from the pacific northwest to
this country all them hairy-legged
liberals are unless you're out in the
woods
and um then i went up into canada
and from there i went straight to uh i
went to france
some friends of my wife and i uh were
getting married in the french
countryside and uh when i got out to the
france countries high
uh countryside de france um
i had i had medieval internet
it's the only way i could describe it
there was no
there was just no internet i could get
text messages from people
but if they sent an accompanying photo
it just would never download so that's i
had basic
that type of [ __ ] so i was recording
podcasts and i tried to send though i
tried to send said podcast and it would
say that they went through and they
never did and then i would get a text
message
from andrew going uh dude i know you're
out there so where's the podcast and i'd
be like check the blue
um wherever the [ __ ] you say that um
yeah so i don't even know where where to
begin man
um
let's do my little run i was in uh
portland oregon i think auburn
washington vancouver
and then i did two shows in calgary in a
park
the first one at like 4 30 in the
afternoon like i was [ __ ] paul simon
i felt so bad for the people in the
crowd by the way shout out to the people
that came out to the four o'clock show
whatever the hell it was
um
sitting in the sun like three quarters
of the crowd just sitting in the sun i'm
watching them
my fellow hawaii people
getting [ __ ] turning from white to
pink
to red by the time i did my closing bit
um i want to thank them for coming out i
it was a great time it was kind of a
little bit bit weird
you know with people who weren't part of
the fest it was a festival that's what i
was kept telling him
yeah i said to my agent why am i doing a
short for in the afternoon he's like oh
it's a festival it's like that's not
really an answer
okay i've done festivals before
and i've performed inside i performed
outside but one thing i can't tell you
was the sun was down
down goes frasier the sun was down
standing there in [ __ ] broad daylight
in a park talking about my dick i
thought i was gonna get arrested
i felt like
i felt like i was set up man
um
yeah that's uh
yeah i was strange but i ended up going
great the crowd was amazing
um
i vaguely recall some older woman came
up and flashed her tits so actually her
bra
with her bra which dean delray said look
like an old pillow case
it's like [ __ ]
you know that that gray
you know when a white becomes that gray
well you're just like i gotta throw this
out or you look up in the sky's that
color and you look like i don't want to
go to work today
i don't want to work on my relationship
i don't want to let this guy in but i'm
going to let the guy in because wherever
i'm going i don't feel like going and
you just delayed me getting there by
another car length thank you sir thank
you sir for being you
um by the way i absolutely [ __ ]
crushed
speaking french
with the french people over there i
[ __ ] killed it i was getting a lot of
smiles like there you go
you bald old [ __ ] you're coming around
like like little nods of like hey that
wasn't bad i'm not saying i was like
[ __ ]
over there reading the
news but i was able to uh
i was able to say to a cab driver excuse
me sir
could you put the windows down
it's really hot back here i was able to
say all of that
i was speaking and uh i know i didn't
say any of that correctly but i said
enough of it correctly oh we miss you
and i was just like yes sorry i was like
that's when you know you have it down
when you start thinking
in that language but i was i was so
surprised and thrilled with the amount
of [ __ ]
that i was able
to convey
um just by knowing how to order
directions
and just knowing uh to go
to want
and uh to buy just knowing all of those
conjugations in the uh
yeah just knowing word like kelka shows
yeah did you ever think uh
blah khelka shows
uh akote
uh and they would be like okay he's
saying uh close by over there you know
and i would just kind of move my hands
like someplace close
and then i take a left make it right
that i don't i could [ __ ] handle it
i actually had the stewards
on the plane going would you prefer if
we just did this in french because i
could tell i was trying to learn it i
was so [ __ ] psyched you know oh billy
oh billy shy boy
billy shy boy that was one when i had a
music contract early in my career billy
shy boy it was a
i was in a boy band
and that's what i went by you know we're
trying to ride the coattails
of um
a new addition
followed by
new kids on the block there was the
third incarnation
of suburban
that was our hook we were suburban white
boys we weren't the cool white boys from
dorchester we were the suburban ones
and i went by billy
shyboy and uh we never got out of the
garage sorry
um
anyway no i was trying to start a medal
banned
in my garage i just wanted to be in a
band
um
so anyway i don't know what let me just
back my way through this whole [ __ ]
tour oh when i was in calgary when i
landed
one of the first things i saw was a big
pickup truck you know i'm a truck guy
now god damn it you know i'm a truck guy
and i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what
uh the guy had freedom written on the
back window
[Laughter]
ah those poor people
freedom
that's where this country's about
freedom like what does that even mean
i mean i do know what it means
uh
i think i know what it means but i mean
freedom went out the window like
i don't know how many [ __ ] decades
ago i don't know when these people are
going to rebel oh i guess they did
i guess they did
um i don't know
it's just like dude we are so [ __ ]
when it comes to freedom right now
i mean what would you attack first if
you really wanted to reclaim whatever
the [ __ ] it is you're claiming and i am
assuming that when you mean reclaim you
don't mean to send women and people who
aren't white back into the [ __ ] stone
ages or you know 20 years ago
um
if you just mean like
the government to stop hassling you man
like i don't know where you would even
begin the first thing you'd have to do
like most coups is you'd have to go
after the media because once you control
the narrative then you control the
thought process so you would have to go
in
and you would have to whack everybody at
fox news and cnn that's the first thing
you would have to do so you could
control the narrative of what it was
that you were doing
um because i can guarantee you
if there was a coup to overthrow the
country
one that looked like it was going to be
successful not that [ __ ] uh
insurrection of [ __ ] whatever that
january whatever the [ __ ] it was
um
a bunch of people with [ __ ] they got at
home depot pushed their way into a
government building my favorite part was
when they actually got all the way in
there
and they didn't know what to do because
there was no plan to even get that far
and then they just started sitting at
desks and putting their feet up like
children that had taken over a school
like oh look at me i'm the principal
take a picture
um
there was that aspect of it and then the
other aspect of it which was [ __ ]
hilarious to me is that a group of
people armed with [ __ ] you get at home
depot could somehow
get all the way in
to whatever that government building was
called
the one with the nice dome
the capitol building
that's where the house of
representatives and the senate sit and
debate things for corporations acting as
though they're doing something for you
um
anyway so i saw that i saw that truck
there so i had fun with that element
um
that was in the crowd
you know
uh telling them that i also had a truck
in the [ __ ] that i was gonna ride on my
back window just to annoy them
just show up with the bat most badass
truck
ever and then just have gender neutral
bathrooms written on the back window
just to [ __ ] annoy people and then
just come out there and just and just be
one of them
loving guns and all of this type of [ __ ]
and they just can't and just see see if
you could get them to get past what you
had written
on the back of your window i keep seeing
those memes about people like writing
their whole um
all of their politics on their pickup
trucks that seems to is that like really
happening
or maybe other people pick up trucks see
it
um i always love it because it's it's
very like
like common man common sense in other
words there's nothing behind it
i i shoot from the hip man i tell it
like it is it's just like you know what
that means i don't read
i don't have nearly enough
uh time put in on this topic but i'm
just like
you know but i am arrogant enough to
think that i can solve it
without needing any in any of the
information like i got one for you
i know this full-on [ __ ] narcissist
not me
um another one this full-on [ __ ] as i
sit here doing a podcast by myself um
i know this full-on [ __ ] narcissist
and for years
from the moment jfk junior's plane went
down
to like
a [ __ ] two years ago
this dude
was telling me without a a [ __ ]
shred of doubt that he knew exactly what
happened and he just made up all of this
[ __ ]
all of this [ __ ] oh
oh i'll tell you what how y'all dude
i'll tell you what happened dude he
didn't even get his license up here
dude he went down to florida they're
like oh god you're a [ __ ] jfk [ __ ]
junior
right
dude he had like [ __ ] eight hours and
the guy just gave him his [ __ ]
license
that's what this guy said
and um
and on and on and on and on and on and
on and on and then he bought a plane
that was beyond his ability and that he
was too cocky because he was a kennedy
and all of this [ __ ] just indicting this
dead person
right
so lo and behold
all freckles here eventually goes out
gets himself a pilot's license and one
day it dawns on him
one of the things that he learned is
that anytime there's an accident there's
an faa report about a year later so i
was like why don't i just read the
report
and i read the report and nothing this
guy said was true this guy made a
youtube video
you know also about it that was
incredible
and um
i was reading saying this guy most of
his hours were with instructors
which most people it isn't because they
can't afford to do that this and he had
done he actually
had passed his written on his instrument
exam
and had experience
you know uh he had like half the hours
he needed
to fly under instrument and all of that
he was an incredibly careful pilot
cautious pilot and all of that he just
ran into a series of things that ended
up being beyond him which can [ __ ]
happen
to anybody
um
which is the scary thing about flying
and all of this [ __ ] so
i went to this guy
hadn't talked to him in years i said hey
dude you know you know i got my pilot's
license right he's like yeah be careful
up there dude
you want to stay on the ground where
everybody's driving 90 text messaging
without [ __ ] looking at the road dude
all these [ __ ] tesla people taking
naps while their car keeps driving like
they're in [ __ ] knight rider that's
where you want to be nice and safe
on the highways where there's a cross
and [ __ ] flowers on the side of the
road every half [ __ ] mile
um and i'm like yeah i know dude i know
it's dangerous you're right you're right
listen
you know uh there's a whole faa report
on that jfk junior thing you should
really read it
and he goes i don't need to read it i go
i'm telling you everything that you're
saying is wrong this guy was actually a
really good pilot really cautious and
all that and i said
and he started saying again what he
thought happened
with full [ __ ] confidence i'm like
dude that's not what happened
i go there's an faa report read it and
he goes i don't need to read it
[Laughter]
[Music]
and i just burst it out laughing
and i was like all right man
what i did and that's the only thing
that shuts somebody that he goes what
what do you mean all right i got nothing
nothing i get it i get it you you know
what happened
well no dude why it's just like i just
told you there's a whole there's a group
of people that that's their job to
figure out what went wrong
you're not even in aviation you don't
even have [ __ ] a model plane and
you're telling me that you know more
than the [ __ ] faa knows without even
reading a [ __ ] report
i got a little heated
just people like that you know what's so
[ __ ] dumb is i know they're never
gonna agree with me but i will [ __ ]
walk up that hill every time and ring
that doorbell every [ __ ] time
what am i looking for what am i looking
to gain that they're gonna be like you
know what bill
you are right
thank you for setting me straight that's
just not gonna happen on any level okay
whatever
um
so anyway so when i saw that i got a big
kick out of that i was like wait you
know i bought a big stupid truck
now i can actually start writing things
on the back and annoying the [ __ ] out of
people with my political opinions
uh well bill you already do it on the
podcast um
all right
where am i going from here
let's talk about uh
yeah we'll just back our way through it
so i
flew back
we were in tours
and we drove up to uh paris which took a
couple of hours got up at six in the
morning
and then we went to uh
charles de gaulle
airport
my daughter had out her laptop
and was watching charlie marrone
try to kick the football and uh
surely um
anyways
um
okay hang on a second
um so we get to the airport
and uh
and you know it's classic
you know just traveling with kids five
and under my son's two years old
you know where the passports my wife has
the passports my mother-in-law had this
duty-free bag of [ __ ] she couldn't
remember where she put it they leave it
in the van
all of this stuff you finally get to the
other side of customs
you always feel at some point someone's
just gonna stop you hot you know
you're just never gonna be able to get
back to your country
so um
we ended up finally getting to the uh
to the airport and something i learned
is my son's a little loud and a little
out of control
because i'm sort of overcompensating
from my childhood so uh i had to become
uh
old firm freckles with him and i'd be
honest with you it took like literally
five minutes in one temper tantrum and
then i i ended up
having the snap and the stair and he
would just look at me when he put his
hands over his eyes
and then peek through his fingers and it
was just like you know
just doing i mean that's like i and i
didn't have to [ __ ] raise my voice or
anything
i just had to sit him down and be like
hey
enough of this apologize to your sister
say you're sorry and that would always
hit him and he'd be like
sorry
and my daughter would be like it's okay
yeah he's kind of like a lunatic or
whatever but despite that he is only two
years old
all right so and he is gonna be on a
plane for like 12 hours and i got to
tell you something
he got on the plane and he was being a
little loud and there was this older
couple in front of us and this [ __ ]
guy is like giving my kid looks and i
was sitting there going like you know i
never thought i had it in me
to slap somebody
that looked like they were pushing 80.
but i was just sitting there i wanted to
look at that guy and be like buddy do
you think you didn't cry when you were
[ __ ] two
you old [ __ ] when you were on a [ __ ]
wooden ship trying not to get scurvy
when you cross this [ __ ] ocean the
last time
he was going can we change our seats
because this this is just going to be
really difficult oh is it really going
to be difficult to go from paris to
[ __ ] los angeles in 11 and a half
hours
[Laughter]
with the live flatbed
um
i am proud to say that in 12 hours there
was three incidents of my son just
wigging out which i think was pretty
[ __ ] good
and um
i stayed up the whole time
i did like 200 laps with them around the
cabin
carrying them um
you know he knew how to say hello he's
such a friendly little guy he'd walk by
and he'd meet people and he'd go bonjour
of course so the stewards and all of
them [ __ ] loved him stuart says
whatever the [ __ ] he's both the male
stewards
and the stewardesses
um
and we ended up we ended up just having
like uh a great time and i sat next to
my daughter
and we basically just laughed and shot
the [ __ ]
for probably half of the flight i just
kept looking at her thinking like how
awesome like this is my daughter this is
amazing
so um i did watch a couple of um
movies
i watched dublin which was not dublin oh
my god i keep calling it dublin oh my
god
ah they're gonna kill me in ireland
i was watching belfast i don't know why
i kept calling it dublin probably
because 90
of my tours over there i always go to
dublin and i only went to belfast once
um
and i got to play that amazing theater
where led zeppelin played um ursula hall
where the first place they played
stairway to heaven live
um
anyway and i remember being in belfast i
remember the guy that was the security
guy
you know who was running ursula hall and
i remember like meeting that guy i was
like and i was like hey man how you
doing and just his whole [ __ ] vibe
you could just feel okay this guy
it was just a different vibe up there
we like all right
this is not the place
to make some wise ass remark
that might be misunderstood
um
but anyway
i saw that movie belfast my apologies
and uh i really enjoyed that it was not
what i thought it was gonna be
by any stretch of the means it was
actually uh
a really cool thing was sort of about
just the human relations
relationships there between you know
husband and wives like her wives how it
affected them
um
and the decisions people had to make
and uh
just pulling families apart and
everything was really a really really
interesting movie so i enjoyed that one
and then i watched that clint eastwood
movie
uh crime macho
and um
that movie i loved i mean anytime
clint's gonna play a cowboy and get on
the horse again and he was driving an
old chevy suburban
um
i i really enjoyed that one too and uh
other than that what did i do i watched
this whole thing that was in french
about
air france
in the movies
and it was just this wonderful series
and they had a thing uh where they were
talking about the concord
the supersonic [ __ ] jet
you could fly from new york city
to france in like three hours and 40
minutes
this was in the late 70s you could do
this
how we went back and they had one
[ __ ] crash
and they douched the whole goddamn thing
how many of the [ __ ] 747s have
crashed i don't see them [ __ ] douche
in that thing it must have just been too
prohibitively expensive but i did see
something recently that they were going
to be bringing supersonic flight back if
they could just somehow
make those things electric
you know now that china bought up all
the lithium deposits around the [ __ ]
world
um we could find a new way to pollute
the skies
there needs to be less people people
that's that's what needs to happen
that's that's the solution
and that is not what i am hearing
from democrats or republicans
go forth and multiply
keep the country hawaii
um
that's one of the theories about that
you know that a whole abortion thing
that it's really not religious based i
mean they're using the media
to stir people up you know i'm not
saying that people aren't against it for
religious reasons but i feel like
they're against it for religious reasons
because they were told that god doesn't
like it
not because god said that
who by the way has been surprisingly
quiet since that book
[Music]
issuing statements right and left like
george steinbrenner when the yankees
were sub 500 and then just not a peep
not a [ __ ] word from the guy but
evidently
he weighed in on abortion a long [ __ ]
time ago and said he didn't [ __ ] like
it um i heard and there's another theory
i'm not saying that this is true
okay i'm not trying to be the guy
that doesn't have answers that sits here
and acts like he has answers because
there's nobody here to debate with me
but i actually read this theory that it
was racially based
because 60 of abortions
were done by hawaii people
that they wanted those they wanted those
white babies
they needed those white babies so that
people who weren't white wouldn't out
[ __ ] us
i don't know
everything sounds [ __ ] nuts to me
um
but anyway my son did great i was so
proud of him
and um
i also be i feel like i became a better
dad because i was embarrassed
like there was a few times where he just
i was telling him to be quiet and he
just would not be quiet i was like wow
my son really doesn't listen to me i
need to fix this and i fixed it really
quick
um
not gonna allow to lie there was a
pretty loud debate from him but i fixed
it and that was it and i was just
thinking to myself i was trying to put
myself in the other people's position
and i was like you know what i get
annoyed a little bit when other kids are
crying but i always understood it and my
whole thing was if the parent was making
an effort to keep the kid quiet then at
the end of the day what are they
supposed to do
what are they supposed to do drug the
kid put a chloroform rag over his
[ __ ] face
um
and those people who give me dirty looks
my whole thing is as long as you never
had kids
as long as you never had kids
then i get it you hate kids and this is
why you didn't have kids i can even
understand that but like if you had kids
and you're still giving those [ __ ]
looks like i just i don't i immediately
assume that you were a [ __ ] parent
um
is that wrong
um
by the way the wedding that we went to
um
was in a castle
on the french countryside and um
it ended with fireworks out on the
terrace i mean it was it was a
once-in-a-lifetime experience that's
what i loved about the wedding was
even even as a guest it was like sort of
a it was a night you were never going to
forget so i was
very psyched and had and that i was
invited to something like that had a
great time and it was one of those
awesome weddings you know where you just
know the people should be together
you know we just like they totally fit
um
and then everybody who came up and gave
speeches was were just crushing it
um it was awesome
because uh i've been to a few i've been
to two weddings
where you're just sitting there going
like i just don't see this connection at
all
i give this
i mean just because breaking up is hard
to do i get 18 months maybe
but there's no way they're going through
the holidays twice there's no [ __ ]
way
trying to pick out that card that says
all of this [ __ ] that you wish you felt
but didn't
i mean there's only so many times you
can buy that card
um
so
the two weddings that i went to that
were like that one of them ended um i
want to say about two years
maybe
two and a half years
um
and the other one they're still together
as far as i know so what the [ __ ] do i
know i do know the one that that
that like
dissolved
quickly
what was cool is it actually dissolved
in a nice way
they were trying to do something i
forget like around the house and they
were just fighting
i just you know they just weren't in
sync
and for whatever reason my buddy just
looked at his wife and said
hey do you want to like just
like not do this
and she was like what he was just like
like this like
it doesn't feel right
and she was just like yeah i know
that's what it was and then he goes do
you like want to like not do this and
she was like
yeah
and then they both laughed
it was one of those things usually when
there's a breakup there's one person's
just like this is the greatest
relationship ever right i've been that
person then he just get hit with that
wet sack of potatoes one day
of like yeah listen i'm not into this at
all oh my god oh god getting dumped
jesus christ then the whole time like ah
i bet she hated my laugh she probably
hated the way i slept
you know
when you're with somebody and you're not
in love with them just every [ __ ]
thing they do after a while
becomes a reason
to like this is how these [ __ ] idiots
you're watching these [ __ ] shows
they kill their spouses because this
this they don't tell you teach how to
break up with somebody how do i get out
of this
how do i get out of this
and then they go from like you know
the worst thing they did was steal candy
bars when they were kids to try to get
away with murder one
i mean jesus [ __ ] christ
talk about not wanting to have that
conversation
you know you're risking like you know if
you if you are a religious person going
to hell for the rest of your life
why would you just stay married and just
like deal have that be your help because
then even then i think god would get mad
at you
i gave you a brain
i gave you a mouth and you you just what
did you do with it huh
you talked to the wrong person you
married the wrong person and then you
[ __ ] stayed in it and you had kids
with the wrong person and they could
feel the [ __ ] vibe and now they're
all out they're all [ __ ] now like god
cares to that point
like he gives a [ __ ]
at that level
i've come back around people that i i
believe in a higher power
all right
i am there but i am not
nor will i ever
i don't think you could ever convince me
that it's it's it's a higher power that
even remotely gives a [ __ ]
when you look at all the [ __ ]
horrible things like take this latest
[ __ ] jerk off
who by the way if he just looked at his
picture it's like this guy shouldn't own
a gun
you know but he just can walk right in
and buy whatever the [ __ ] he wants
because he's an american right
he goes out and did what he did now
here's my thing god made that person
so how do these religious people sit
there you know
and all of that [ __ ] horseshit
about god and the devil i just love how
the devil is somehow like the same rank
as god
like you got two choices
the guy who created everything
or this [ __ ] guy
and you can actually choose this [ __ ]
guy
and do something
beyond [ __ ] evil
like what happened in buffalo texas and
now chicago
sure there's a rally going right now you
know make it easier make it easier to
get
guns um
which is another thing i would love to
have talk to um
um
gun owners for some reason i keep
throwing this out there and i just never
seem to get the [ __ ] emails
like uh i understand that whole thing
where you don't just want the government
to have arms
um
you know in case they get too oppressive
that the people can fight back
what about modern technology and how far
ahead they are with the weaponry that
they have
versus what
you as a citizen can purchase
at a uh
you know at
a gun store or walmart or whatever
i mean what they have access
what they have the fact that now
you know some nerd from the math team
can be [ __ ] john rambo with a drone
five states away
like how does one combat something like
that
which once again i actually think that
the government having that level of
weaponry versus the citizens is the
least of our
problems um
i would say that it's what that were
divided
because of these 24-hour [ __ ] news
networks
because the bottom line is is if
everybody just said well [ __ ] it then
all right well we just won't go to work
and we're gonna stop paying taxes
and then none of you [ __ ] get
to eat
now what are you gonna do hey hey
hey richie's dig your own ditches
you can have like all these
non-violent you know the problem is is
they get to use the military on their
own people and they have to follow
orders
i have more stripes in my shirt and i
told you to point that gun at your own
[ __ ] people
oh this is getting deep all right let's
uh is it getting deep the topic's
getting deep i don't know that what was
said was that deep
um
all right
oh we were at the castle we stayed there
after the wedding we were like the last
couple that left we stayed there oh my
god had this amazing pool
and when i was in vancouver i bought
these uh swimming goggles they actually
had a speedo store
um oh my god i couldn't wear anything in
there i just i just hate my body right
now i just i don't want to talk about it
but the goggles
they uh you know they had the regular
you know i'm in a days inn they have an
indoor slash outdoor pool something has
been pissed in let me jump in that they
had those ones and then they had the uh
are you competing for a spot on the
national team
and i was like i don't know why i was
like let me get those
i'll take those they're [ __ ]
incredible
and i was in lapacy however you say pool
um
this is what i would do i would sit by
the pool
right
i just [ __ ] chill out
and there was like a like a i don't like
a [ __ ] bog or some [ __ ] like some
pond that you couldn't even see the
water had all this green [ __ ] on it and
that [ __ ] thing there was so much
chatter coming from that pond it was
across the road
oh by the way my son imitates the uh
the police cars over there he kept going
and he loved him
and um
my daughter was speaking french
uh with this
uh the the flight attendants they
absolutely [ __ ] loved her
um and said that she spoke great french
and all of that type of stuff i'm
actually starting to speak french with
my daughter it's so [ __ ] cool
um
but my son loves planes motorcycles
helicopters trucks and cars and i every
day he
you know now he wants to come out to the
garage it's kind of good i start my old
truck up i pull it out of the drive you
know the the garage and everything
and when we landed
at lax and
he saw all the other airplanes he had a
[ __ ] meltdown
and he was pointing at them and i was
going yeah buddy like airplane he was
just going like that airplane
no no as we were walking away and i
finally figured out that he thought that
we could just go and sit in them
and play in all the airplanes so with
his cute little two-year-old mind he was
like why are we going this way
we should all go play on those planes
and pretend we're flying them and the
trucks and the buses so we finally had
to be like the planes are going bye-bye
planes are going bye-bye and he'd be
like
he's like buy my plane
buy my planes
it absolutely
[ __ ] broke my heart but um
i was also totally psyched that he was
into uh
he's into planes and trucks and all of
that [ __ ] all right i am babbling here
babbling by the way my buddy
comedian bt was telling me that uh this
f1 race might have been one of the best
ones ever
i got to see it i briefly saw a
highlight before i shut it off lewis
hamilton was in the hunt
which is [ __ ] awesome as much as i
like to to tease that guy and everything
it sucks when his car isn't good and i
actually met an f1 huge fan who was
going to that race at the wedding and he
was saying that uh i was going to weird
how his teammate has a better car and he
said no he's the more experienced driver
so he's going to be able to to guide
them
easier on what the car needs
and uh you know what's going to happen
that they're getting their [ __ ] together
and it's just going to be a [ __ ]
it's just going to be unbelievable
racing for the rest of the year that's
what i'm hoping so anyway i have to
watch that my dvr
recorded it all right look who it is
everybody it's indochito
you know whether you're going to be a
groom in a wedding party or a lucky
guest everyone wants to look their best
for a wedding with a custom fitted suit
from indochino you'll feel great feel
confident and enjoy the big day without
fussing over your clothes hey i was at
that wedding i was at that wedding and
somebody would you know i was sweating
this guy's suit man i love that suit
what is it he goes this is a 75 dollar
suit i'm telling you
75 and these guys are like twice that
they they got like
a couple hundred these shirts start from
79 bucks you can look great at a [ __ ]
wedding especially if it's customized
because his pattern and everything was
totally different it might have been an
indochino suit
choose every detail on a shirt
shirt dinner jacket and more at
affordable prices that may surprise you
for fully customized pieces if i was a
young man and i was going to a wedding
and i wanted to stand out without
breaking the bank and getting the ladies
to come over me and ask me if i like it
shaken or stirred there
um i'd get an indochino suit
that'd be my game plan
i'd do that and i'd learn how to do the
electric slide and that would be it man
it's raining um choose
[Music]
uh i wasn't going to say men there but
okay but i i'm respecting the fact that
this is a a an advertising read and i'm
going to do it correctly here choose
every detail on a shirt
suit dinner jacket and more at
affordable prices that may surprise you
for fully customized pieces every suit
is made to your exact measurements and
you can customize every detail create a
suit that fits you and your style
perfectly with options for fabrics lapel
shape custom monograms statement linings
and more the best part indochino starts
suits start from just 429
it shirts from 7.99
um indochino
also offers a completely custom i always
feel like this is too much like i'm
ready to buy here just let's get to the
[ __ ] information but they got another
paragraph here
indochino also offers completely custom
fitted shirts casual wear and more get a
wardrobe personalized to your style and
taste without spending a fortune yeah
look at that
look at that right there look at that
copy it just you just put a picture in
my head
are you going to [ __ ] college with
all your [ __ ] that nobody else has and i
mean i don't know there's just something
about him he has a sense of style right
and next thing you know you're getting
banged on a bluff on the way to the quad
are those college words i never went
i mean i commuted so i sort of went
me and the janitor had the same
experience uh there's always adding
they're always adding new pieces and
options so you can stay on trend and in
style explore their relaxed yet refined
approach oh god i have to get an
off-campus apartment i have one of those
it's called living with your parents
explore their relaxed yet refined
approach to spring suits with their new
spring pastels if you got a big day
coming up getting the perfect look is no
big deal with indochino get 50 off any
purchase of 3.99
or more by using the promo code burr
b-u-r-r indochino.com that's 50 off of
purchase at 3.99 or more at
n o i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o-d com promo code
birth all right look who it is now
ah christ who is it now who's at the
door oh my god it's solo stove
stove
toots soul
um
life's best moments happened around a
roaring fire
well i don't know about that i think
it's the end of a lot of people's lives
happened around a roaring fire and a
smokeless fire pit from solo stove a
controlled roaring fire i think they
need controlled
in the copy
life's best moments happen around a
roaring fire jesus christ honey wake up
right i mean come on you got to say look
i'm gonna you know what i'm gonna take a
little
a little uh uh podcast host
power moment here i'm gonna change this
coffee all right
i'm gonna change the copy here life's
best moments happen around a controlled
roaring fire
the fire is nice and warm but it's not
going anywhere and you decide how close
it gets to you not the other way around
and a smokeless fire pit from so you
have the fire making decisions
um
fire was not made in god's image lock
way were
and a smokeless fire pit from solo stove
makes your outdoor moments even more
memorable because instead of having to
constantly dodge campfire fumes jesus
christ
you can sit back relax and actually
enjoy the fire and not worry about
getting burned to death i think that
that's what solo stove is taking out of
the equation here the fire getting out
of control and suddenly uh you know
you know should you see solo stoves or
these [ __ ] that do [ __ ] gender
[ __ ] reveals of their babies
in the middle of a dry wooded area get a
solo stove you [ __ ] [ __ ] uh there's
nothing like a roaring fire to bring you
back to what matters
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i swear to god if you just get me away
from this roaring fire god i'm not gonna
drink any more i'm gonna be nicer to my
wife i i understand what matters now oh
a controlled fire
dude why am i working so hard
look at my wife look at her gorgeous
face with the flames flickering ever so
safely away from her uh the
things
uh the things digital
what the things digital distractions
and the frenzy
that can't be right
brings you back to what matters the
things digital distractions
what things has got to be the wrong word
there and the frenzy of everyday life
make too easy to forget
well it brings you back to what matters
the things digital distractions in the
frenzy of everyday life make too easy to
forget oh that was all one sentence
but they made it two sentences all right
stainless steel conduct construction
designed
to regulate airflow and burn more
efficiently speaking of stainless steel
my wedding ring
um
that's the kind of precious metal you
get as the husband
they melt down a toaster
into a circle
there you go buddy
um
i uh i do this dumb thing where i take
my wedding ring off when i put on lotion
because i don't like when the lotion
gets underneath the ring and i always
set the ring on top of my wallet and
when i'm on the road i get super
paranoid if i take the ring off but i
still i don't know why i'm just gonna
stop doing it so i took the ring off it
was six in the morning
six in the morning at the waffle house
um i actually heard the original version
it was three a.m at the pancake house
and then jay-z goes no i switched it a
little bit i say 4am at the waffle house
and then they were like okay that's
different
um
anyway so i i uh
had this [ __ ] i took the ring off
in the bathroom
and it wasn't until we were like two
hours into our drive going back up to
paris i looked down and it wasn't on my
finger and i went oh my god oh my god oh
my god my wife's like what what
what i'm like
i might have left my ring at the
at the hotel she was totally cool
because she was with me you know what i
mean i think if you're on the road by
yourself you're like i think i left my
ring at the hotel i don't think your
wife's gonna be cool but i was like no i
put it i think it's in my toiletry bag
and we called the hotel and they didn't
have it so i go i i know it's there it
has to be there
and my toiletry bag was in the big bag
that i was checking and we were going
through customs and i'm like look it's
either there it's not i'm not doing this
[ __ ] now
and um
i flew the whole way back without the
ring on it it felt really weird i didn't
even realize all the subconscious things
i do
with it because it's not totally like i
didn't want it to be hon i got okay i'm
gonna maybe i'm over sharing here but i
have like giant [ __ ]
like my knuckles are bigger than the
[ __ ] finger meat behind it so it had
to be big enough to get around the
knuckles
i basically have an hourglass
finger shape
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh that's another thing i watched i
watched this thing on [ __ ] uh
oh i'm supposed to be doing copy here
right stainless steel construction
design and airflow burn more efficiently
so little smoke you wonder
why is this so how's there's so much
fire uh it's the perfect catalyst for
getting outside and spending time with
friends and family building lasting
memories around a solo stove i've found
my ring by the way right now you can get
a big discount on all fire pits during
solo stove's fourth of july sale and use
promo code bur b-u-r-r at solostove.com
s-o-l-o-s-t-o-v-e.com
for an extra 10 off that solostove.com
promo code burr put on your indochino
suit stand next to a controlled raging
fire
huh
and meet the he she they are your dreams
that's solostove.com promo code burp for
ten dollars off on top of their
incredible fourth of july uh sale
discount but hurry the fourth of july
sale ends
july 10th
um
so anyway uh
i landed and i got home and i opened my
toiletry bag and i'm like there it is
and then it turned out to be the circle
from the scissors
for my nose hairs and i was like oh no
i was like i know it's in here i know
it's in here i know it's in here and i
went in and it was there and i put it on
and everything was cool but my wife was
like ridiculously cool
she goes well we can go to uh we can
just go get another one
i thought she was going to be like oh
coochoo that was the one i put on your
finger when we got married yeah but
she's not like that
like every year we kind of like
we're not good with like dates
like what do you want to do in an ad
wait once i ran over ah [ __ ] was that
yesterday
um all right master class
master class have you always wanted to
be a slave owner but didn't know how to
do it well fortunately there's
masterclass
making america great again kidding all
right master class everybody with
masterclass you can learn from the
world's best minds
anytime anywhere
and at your own pace learned a barbecue
from aaron franklin i so want that to be
aretha franklin
um
you know
i always heard she could cook she was on
the road she liked the throw down
and also the greatest voice of all time
am i crazy uh learn to barbecue from
aaron franklin
skateboarding from anthony
tony
or learn songwriting and producing from
alicia keys whatever
[Music]
with 100 classes from a range of
world-class instructors that thing
you've always wanted to do is closer
than you think
jerking off in public they got homeless
steve
uh master class is accessible on your
phone web or smart tv offering classes
on a wide variety of topics all taught
by world-class masters at the top of
their fields each class is broken out
into individual video lessons usually
around 10 minutes long
memorize things that neil degrasse tyson
says to plumbers
um hundreds of videos
is it me or is that guy never talking to
scientists he's always talking to some
meathead like me that's like going like
wow neil you're really smart i want to
see neil talk to another scientist i
guarantee you the guy's going shut the
[ __ ] up neil all right i'm not some rube
you found at a bus stop
all right this isn't a podcast all right
we're in the lab [ __ ]
huh you want to take out a graduated
cylinder and show me what you got huh
neil
why do i know your middle name like you
[ __ ] invented something
you know what you invented talking to
people way dumber than you are so you
can seem smart and get some [ __ ]
celebrity [ __ ] that's what you're doing
neil
meanwhile i'm in the [ __ ] lab no one
knows my name i'm out here curing [ __ ]
the [ __ ] did you do during colvin
all right hundreds of video lessons from
100
100 plus of today's most brilliant minds
are available anytime anywhere
on ios what the [ __ ] does that mean i
have to look that up every week ios
it's a small eye so it's got to be apple
because that's their brand
they own the lowercase i
um android desktop apple tv amazon fire
tv and
rogue uh i highly recommend you check it
out get unlimited access to every master
class i'd like to do the alicia keys one
right and then sit down like bill murray
and groundhog day
you know
and start singing some r b hits from the
late 90s and early 2000s
he couldn't sing but you know he was
tickling those keys like alicia keys
should we call him billy keys how did he
do it he went to masterclass.com
burr that's masterclass.com
right now for 15
off
all master classes is it is
all right
lastly but not leastly but not leastly i
don't i don't
want to start any any
ill will between advertisers on this
podcast can you tell i'm also typing in
a podcast uh a password as i'm doing
this
um all right
it's simply safe everybody isn't that
what we all want to feel
just simply safe simply safe everybody
you know today's episode of the monday
morning podcast is brought to you by
simply safe home security
i believe
jaquah
i believe home security should be the
safest place
oh i believe home
should be the safest place on earth
for every family
yeah for every family i don't think it
should be the safest place i mean you're
dealing with like nuclear reactors and
serial killers that you lock up you want
to make sure that they're locked up
safely
simply safe maximum security prisons
uh that's why i i use and recommend
simply safe simply safe is an advanced
whole home security that puts you your
home and your family's safety first
here's why i love it is why i love it i
love standing in the kitchen and [ __ ]
looking all around my house standing in
the kitchen
knowing there's nobody there knowing
that there's not somebody coming into
the house that i would then have to
[ __ ] sacrifice myself to as the rest
of the family ran out uh simply safe
offers comprehensive protection not only
against intruders and burglary but
against expensive home hazards from
flooding to fires with 24 7 professional
monitoring simplisafe's agents take
action the moment a threat is detected
dispatching police or first responders
in an emergency even if you're not home
simply safe does it be funny you come
home there's a bunch of firefighters in
there smoking cigars uh can i help you
oh sorry uh there was an alarm and we
didn't think you're going to be back
until tomorrow simply safe uses
proprietary video verification
technology so that monitoring agents can
visually confirm the threat in order to
get higher priority 911 dispatch
monitoring plans are affordable
affordably priced at a dollar a day with
no long-term contracts or hidden fees
because feeling safe at home
shouldn't break the bank
you can customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes at
simply safe.com
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus twenty percent off
with interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.com
that's s i m
p l i
a
dot com slash burr all right
it's time for a little bit of water here
all right
moving on things to do
in albuquerque
for two hundred dollars things to do in
albuquerque
um
hey billy
bercueno
bequeno it's pronounced burkeno captain
freckle chest billy burkeno
but kenyo
uh i'm a born and raised
albuquerque native and this is
to your nana fan who asked about things
to do here in albuquerque what does
burkenow mean that's got to be some sort
of insult towards me
but daniel uh when the weather permits
she could take her grandson to the top
of
sandia peak on the tram
or the
petroglyph
uh national park which has ancient
drawings on extinct volcanic rocks
although if the rocks are extinct then
what the [ __ ] are the drawings on i'm
only saying this because he sounds
spelled that petroglyph
and he goes yes very good making fun of
me like you're [ __ ] smart
if you were smart you would be listening
to this podcast all right so you're
guilty by association in old town
albuquerque we have
an awesome 100 year old church and
shopping which is right up the street
from the zoo and the aquarium
in october uh
[ __ ] sea lions what are you doing
time albuquerque ah [ __ ] you're never
getting out uh in october if you're in
the san diego zoo you have hope you can
smell it you can hear it you can hear
the ocean in october
is the international ballooned fiesta
which sells fast
oh my wife went to that
we have more than green chile and
breaking bad in which you rock by the
way oh now he's being nice thank you sir
uh come visit us nana and you always
you'll always have a home here bill much
love to the family
thanks and
singa to me so
sigatum
i'm assuming that means go [ __ ] yourself
uh respectfully
okay real jobs hey bill i'm 35.
all right
not old i'm not young
just sort of hanging there in limbo
too old to go to a club
too young for an aarp card
i used to work in tech now i own a diner
i saw you posted something to your
instagram about diners and the dying
breed of a local restaurant
um oh yeah there was this whole thing
about how um
diners were uh
during covid got really got hit really
hard and these guys were talking about
what it takes to run a diner which is
really interesting to me because it
looks easy
you know
got that flat drop grill going
you know let me get let me get out let
me get two over easy
you know
they're usually making [ __ ] that you
know how to make i just didn't realize
all the overhead and all of that crap
you know people chewing and screwing
dining and dashing
bipping and bopping um i had a very i
have very little experience wait a
second what am i
okay it's been a lot of work but it's
very rewarding oh this is something this
person does i guess
i had very little experience but i
sought out knowledge from some veterans
of the diner business and they were very
happy to help covet really destroyed a
lot of these businesses is there
anything better than a great diner and
what's a great diner it's clean and they
butter the toast they don't bring the
[ __ ] toast over with butter to the
side that's cold and then i gotta tear
apart the [ __ ] warm bread that you're
calling toast
sorry i've read that half
of all second and third generation
diners closed down
seven out of the ten in my city closed
down by the end of 2021 so i believe it
government didn't do [ __ ] for actual
small businesses how did they go out of
business when people were ordering food
i guess they weren't ordering from them
dude is there anything better than going
to a [ __ ] diner when you don't have
anything to do that morning you got you
got the local paper
that's the greatest and you watch all
these people [ __ ] walking in
hey mark
um government didn't do [ __ ] for actual
small businesses the loans were
exploited by big companies and the math
never added up in terms of the damage
done versus the money they gave out i
really hope uh
another wave of hipsters come back
around and start bringing the old stuff
back so you have somewhere to drink your
root beer float you dandy
um
yeah so do i oh what a surprise big
companies taking
advantage
of uh money being handed out by the
government uh taking advantage of the
bankruptcy laws and that type of [ __ ]
that's what rich people do that's what
they do and then they act like they're
one of you yes they do
and then what happens they fall off a
bicycle
you see that there a little trump jab
little [ __ ] joe biden bears well
that's okay you want level trashing
trashing of both sides with no salute
that's what i offer people
i trash both sides
and offer no solutions
that's what we do here
at the monday morning podcast new job
wants to track me
oh god
dear bill there's a mandate at my new
job that requires my work
phone be tracked
this wouldn't be an issue but on my
first day i had lunch with the guy who
was giving his notice at the end of the
week
he wasn't too disgruntled i asked him
why he was going to leave
and he he told me with a straight face
that the company oversteps some bounds
i love this guy they always steps and
bounds them out of here they sent him a
gift card for his birthday to a place
that he shops at except he never told
anyone he shopped there
and it's a niche store
you know what happened if we all
rebelled against that they would still
know that about us they just wouldn't be
dumb enough to send that gift card he
had trip how would they know how [ __ ]
creepy that is he attributed to them
reading all his work emails
or tracking the browser on his computer
and had no shame in using that info to
buy him a birthday gift it's a huge pay
increase so i think i'll stick it out
for a few months because i have bills
and student loans well that's how they
get you but i'm going to be very careful
about what i say and do ps i'm writing
this from a rogue phone with a vpn so
don't worry i'm not a [ __ ] i think more
people need to do that but then you know
what they do they they would start their
own rogue phone under a different
[ __ ] name they'll get you they're
gonna get you
i given up
i've quit
all right
my only line of defense is to live the
most boring life
anybody has ever seen
all right anybody who's tracking me
right now they're they're like wow this
guy's really into watching people power
wash driveways
um it's not all that and then every once
in a while there's a porno thrown in
there like where the [ __ ] did that come
from um new segment idea lifestyles
dear bill the trill
you've talked a lot about different ways
of living
and what the benefits are to different
location i'd like to propose a new
segment about the lesser discussed more
specific ways of life
and during different time periods
firstly for this potential segment i'd
like to suggest river life
is a very interesting way to go river
life
in a van down by the river like the
chris farley bit more specifically in
the 1800s i recently saw a photo of a
home on a river
that was used frequently for travel and
trade
oh so people were using oh we're using
the river for travel and trade can you
imagine sitting on your front porch
watching some random people just float
by
yeah wondering if they didn't kill
somebody in a different state uh this is
pretty that's pretty wild now
of course
i'd have a musket ready to go i oh but
you're also talking like time travel
because i don't think anybody uses a
river
it's like a bunch of fur trappers going
up and down the [ __ ]
allegheny uh of course i'd have a musket
ready to go i'd be
it'd be great to have long days of
sitting along a steady current thoughts
on river life
my question would be
how do you pay your bills
because there's a way
to do river life
where you don't pay anything
you just have to be
wait wait it's a river it's not like
you're on a lake
you're out there you're on a [ __ ]
river
so you're floating you're you're heading
places
what happens when your foundation is too
deep for like the [ __ ]
white water and all of that i got i got
to learn more about river life or is
your house anchored
i got one for you why don't you just put
a [ __ ] house out on a random lake
you know where there's enough [ __ ]
how long could you have it out there
before people like what the [ __ ] is that
guy doing is he paying any taxes every
morning he comes out
whenever he pulls in he goes inside he
[ __ ] eats it for breakfast
occasionally he comes to shore when he
gets
mercury poisoning and he eats a couple
of squirrels i don't think that guy has
to jump
you know you know when some [ __ ]
[ __ ] would put up a gopro and film
the guy and rat him out
instead of looking at that one person
you know
and being happy that they're free
right
all right overrated underrated
um i will tell you though i have like an
unbelievable urge to live in the middle
of nowhere if it wasn't for the racist
morons that you run into out there
i would do it in a second but i can't
move an interracial family into the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere i mean i just
started a netflix series if i did that
all right overrated underrated
underrated tank tops
wife beat us
uh started wearing them at my new job as
a grave digger
when it started getting hot out total
game changer but don't you have like the
backhoe and all of that [ __ ]
jesus christ is this the same guy living
on the rivers in the 1800s extremely
comfortable extremely affordable and if
you get anything on it who cares it's a
wife beater you're supposed to get
stains on it start wearing them
everywhere started wearing them
everywhere at work the gym around the
house and playing pickup ball it's a
great clothing option but
a big t-shirt
would like you to think otherwise um
well there's different ones too
you know what i mean there's this the
wife beater
cut
you know like like like jeans have
straight leg bootleg grape smuggler
uh swing low sweet chariot [ __ ]
um onyx cut right they got all of that
[ __ ] but like wife beaters are the same
way
you know you have that yeah every once
in a while my wife gets out of line and
i give her a [ __ ] smack they got that
classic cut
but then they have the uh the freddie
mercury gay guy cut
which it's a it's a higher quality
uh much more flattering cut but then you
got to be like jacked like a gay dude
though that's the only thing you can't
eat carbs in the other one the other one
you can walk around
the uh sort of the the heterosexual cut
right are there really is there a gay
cut in a heterosexual cut when it comes
to tank tops but there is the
metrosexual who floats between both
sides there's probably that cut
somewhere
anyway
i know what you're saying though if you
get like the classic you know
straight guy
wife beater you can walk around with
like spaghetti sauce and like part of a
meatball on your beer belly but if you
get the freddie mercury cut
uh people are gonna be offended if
you're not jacked
you know
yet another example
of how easy it is to be straight
you know
you can be fat and wear a [ __ ] tank
top and you don't get any [ __ ] unlike
these poor
gay people who if they wear a tank top
you know
they have to get hassled man
i don't know where that went i just made
up all of that [ __ ] um okay where am i
overrated cards a few years back my
family stopped doing birthday christmas
and any hallmark oh overrated getting
cards you always felt cards were stupid
unless you bought a blank one
i always felt weird like if i bought a
mass-produced card that said a bunch of
romantic [ __ ] and i gave it to my wife
and she was like oh my god that was so
nice
i always want to be like oh my god i
know and 1500 other women in this
[ __ ] area code are reading it right
now
um
like can you imagine if you actually
wrote a card
if you wrote a card
in your own penmanship
but you plagiarized some romantic [ __ ]
that somebody else said and they found
out
like it would totally change their
perception of you
but i think because like the plagiarism
is so [ __ ]
there not plagiarism the uh the fact
that it's it is somebody else's words
that you've purchased
um
it's so out in the open that it's
invisible and they never stop to think
like
he doesn't think any of this [ __ ]
[Music]
somebody else thought this [ __ ] who were
they thinking of when they wrote who was
what was this written for
um and that person who writes this stuff
are they actually in love or are they
writing to some fantasy person that they
never had the nerve to talk to or their
idea of what love is because they're a
sociopath who knows what the [ __ ] you're
handling that's why i always go with the
blank card
anyway it's awesome saves a couple of
bucks
um
along with the hassle of going to the
store and looking for a card that
doesn't suck
um it always felt
like an empty gesture
anyway
anyways
uh and a text or a phone call is a lot
more personal and meaningful i think a
phone call is a text is still a blow-off
hey
happy birthday dude
i'll tell you underrated anyway keep up
the great work and i cannot wait to see
your movie in theaters and a new special
from red rocks oh yeah the red rock
special is coming
uh
on
i think july 12th or something like that
maybe a week from this friday friday
uh the [ __ ] was i just gonna say that
just gave me an idea
and i moved on to another idea and my
brain works like a [ __ ] straight line
so i i'm not gonna remember it
we were talking about cards
i always felt like an empty gesture you
had text oh texting
i'll tell you what i'm done doing i am
done responding
to a sea of texts
on random holidays like fourth of july
there was like five people sent me hey
man
happy fourth of july i didn't respond to
any of them i'm not [ __ ] i'm not
spending my fourth of july
going hey bro happy fourth of july to
you too
and then that starts a conversation
same thing with happy father's day you
know what's the worst is when you get to
happy father's day and you can tell it's
just a cut and paste
it just says happy father's day
exclamation point i'm not responding to
that
all right i need to see my name in there
and see a little bit of thought then
then you can guilt me into responding
i'm not [ __ ] doing it
um i'm actually i think i'm not gonna do
it for christmas
you know that you gotta like take like
10 minutes or whatever to just sit okay
i'm gonna deal with all of these [ __ ]
things and then the worst is
these [ __ ] people that send that [ __ ]
you then say hey thanks a lot merry
christmas to you too and then they write
something else back
it's like this this isn't this isn't a
conversation that's what i'm starting
here so i'm just i'm i'm done with all
of that maybe that's what you do just
tell everybody i'm just gonna let you
know i'm not wishing you a merry
christmas
via text okay it's happening right now
merry christmas i said it i'm done i'm
not responding to your your your spam
happy holidays horseshit
all right the only one you can't get out
of is your birthday
but even then what you do is you write
a little paragraph
you copy it and then you just paste it
to each one
okay
and i know what you're thinking well
there's not a name it doesn't come off
as personal exactly and then maybe next
year they don't wish you a happy
birthday
and then you can actually go out
and enjoy your birthday why does your
birthday involve you having to take 10
minutes out of your day to write
everybody back
that wiggled their thumbs for you
huh
do you think davey crockett or any of
the other founding fathers in this
country ever had to do that
huh
stop in the middle of their oppressing
of other people to take out a feather
and write a [ __ ] letter
oh thanks man
uh
and just so you know i let everybody
know that the raccoon hat idea was yours
all the best davy crockett um all right
that's it everybody i'm outta here uh
jetless
au voir
um
yeah i think that's it i was just
thinking i'm gonna go i'm gonna move to
france i just need three months
three months and i'll take french
lessons and all that be [ __ ] hardcore
and then i can do what i've always
wanted to do which is go to france do a
show only in french and just trash them
um [ __ ] guys i swear to god they're
customer service
that's their [ __ ] dude
when you go to france if you ask them
just say hey my leg is hanging off i'm
gonna bleed to death their first
response is like i'm sorry miss you
there's nothing we can do that you gotta
like elevate your voice
not like yell at them but you just gotta
be like
you gotta like wake them out of their
lizzie fan whatever the [ __ ] it is that
they just don't give a [ __ ] you gotta
like remind them
okay i was almost gonna say something
really bad there i'm not gonna say it
all right that's uh
i don't need to start an international
incident here that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves i will check in on you on
thursday
you